as GOP gubernatorial candidate Christine
Drazen continues to Surge and she joins
us right now to explain more Christine
thanks for joining us look we talk all
the time about people stepping up it's
it's surprising to me I mean it's great
that it's in play but your state has
just been suffering so much what is your
message to the people of Oregon that
seems to be changing this race
you know oregonians are demanding better
they're demanding better from their
leaders what we're experiencing has been
a decade of decline under Progressive
extreme single party leadership in our
state and we are feeling it across the
whole state but especially in Portland
where they are less safe today than they
have ever been before we're seeing mom
and pop shops close up we're seeing
National chains exit our beautiful city
and instead we are leaving our city to
people who are abusing hard drugs which
are now legal in our state who in fact
are forming encampments that are
refusing to leave public spaces our city
needs change our state needs new
leadership and that's what oregonians
are responding to you know we saw of
course in deep blue San Francisco that
families are families right parents are
parents you want there's no Democrats
don't want to have to step on syringes
and human feces when they take their
kids out to a park I mean this is really
a nonpartisan issue and yet as a as a
republican it what is there difficulty
and a willingness to hear the message I
mean what kind of a feat what kind of
feedback are you getting from your
constituents
portlanders themselves are asking for
leaders that are willing to stand up for
their quality of life they want to be
safe in their own in their own yards
they want to be safe when their kids
walk to school this is not partisan to
your point this is entirely about
Community safety and a quality of life
that portlanders should demand and
expect from their leaders they're not
getting it from their leaders right now
and that's why my roadmap for Oregon's
future makes Public Safety and Community
safety across our state a central focus
of my efforts and you can find more
information at Christine fororegon.com
well good luck to you obviously and good
luck to the people of Oregon because
what happened in Portland really
frightened the entire nation as we
watched that unfold in 2020 and this is
about the quality of life and The Human
Condition and everyone deserves better
Christine thank you very much for
joining me tonight I appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling and now says you will not get
it anywhere else